you what do you think of the Kanye going
on well Jamie's can't be fully informed
he talks about every morning Jamie's got
many many theories he's got a one of
those mind boards his house was got
index cards leading to the center yeah
Kanye's record releases in the center
and then all these things spray out to
ease ease and and flip-flops and all
these slot slides and he's got a bunch
of theories along the way I've never
heard your theory but does it involve
the car accident that he had right
before he became popular that like I
think he has brain damage from this car
axle those are the people that honestly
think that he is still on he are sorry
he said he was on opioids from getting a
lipo actually because a lot of the media
scrutiny on him being fat he said led
him to go getting lipo led him to having
a painkiller addiction and he was on an
opioid thing and he was very afraid when
he went to the psycho hospital that he
was gonna get killed people are gonna
take him away for all the [ __ ] he was
saying so he did have some issues and I
think he's publicly said he has been on
some other medication so he might be on
or off of it right now well also he
should definitely run for president then
hippitty scoop I mean now he's in it's
perfect he's got all the right
ingredients I would take Kayne over
Trump any day though here's that thing
that you're out of your mind here's that
thing you just said though about the the
accident you know that's the story of
Sam Kinison as well oh yeah yeah Sam
Kinison was a when he was a boy he
apparently was like super normal kid and
then he got hit by a car really bad and
from that point on he became a different
person came wild and reckless and crazy
it's that it's that what football
players getting their head head fighters
yeah yep and murder their wife though J
Simpson
you know that his doctor said that they
would use that as a defense they would
consider using that as a defense if that
trial was to happen today 100% it's like
that other guy the guy ended up killing
himself the football player mark was his
name
he went to jail he hung himself Martina
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Adrian what's his name Jamie yeah but
they're saying that he probably had that
to it 100%
100% it's not a matter of whether or not
you have brain damage it's a matter of
how much how much do you have and can
you work with it you know that's what I
mean
if you get hit in the head a lot you you
have brain damage your brain does not
want to get hit it's just not normal
Aaron Hernandez suffered from most
severe CT he ever found in a person his
age he's kind of like Brendan Schaub
looks like it yeah Brendan's way more
keto right now very thin a brain like
his in someone younger than someone 40
and 46
he's like 25 yeah dude I'm telling you
there is a [ __ ] epidemic of this [ __ ]
it includes all sorts of people that get
their head hit whether it's BMX guys
that are constantly crashing I mean you
think about how many times BMX guy will
crash in his career how many head head
bumps he takes skateboarders notorious
for doing crazy [ __ ] wiping you know the
older you get does it look kind of like
a pit bull does it swell and it gets
worse